Good morning John.
My new office is set up over here.
We have the Games with Hank, and over here,
we have Vlogbrothers, and over here is my
actual desk where I sit.
This is just a picture of you.
Oh it's your puff is a bird.
I'll put it full screen, so everybody can
see it.
Okay John, it's kind of easy to forget how
cool the things we get to do are.
I get to have a channel where I just play
video games.
You get to have a fictional soccer team...
that helps fund a real soccer team.
We get to work in a new medium that, despite
what people who work in it say, no one understands
or knows what to do with.
Crash Course is now being used as a tool in
literally thousands of schools.
You got to hang out with Bill Gates, a guy
who would be the richest person in the world
if he hadn't given so much of his money away...
and just talk about the complexities of market
forces on rural agriculture in Ethiopia.
What?
And in the last, like, four days, this community
has raised $260,000 to help people who don't
have access to clean water, get access to
clean water.
I spent some time this week watching those
donations come in, and the most common thing
people say -- they get to leave a comment
if they want to -- is "I'm sorry I couldn't
give more."
And I don't spend enough time thinking about
how amazing this is -- just the weird and
wonderful position that has been granted to
us by two things:
One: pure, dumb luck, and two: the people
who are watching this right now.
Just like I kinda get used to how I get to
do cool stuff now, people who are a part of
things or watch things forget that they're
the reason that the thing exists.
By spending time watching this video, you
are granting me power.
And it's kinda weird to me that in a world
of infinite content, where there's 30 Rock
and Breaking Bad and PewDiePie and cat videos,
that you choose to watch this.
What-what-why?
Your time is a gift, and I am honored that
you give it to me.
But let's also have a little bit of real talk
here.
I am still insecure.
I still, like, get sad sometimes.
And I don't struggle with depression, I don't
think; I just have a normal amount of sadness,
and sometimes I don't want to do stuff and
feel unmotivated and undeserving of the things
that I have.
And I think that's rational, like, I don't
-- there's nothing special about me that means
that people should be watching me on the internet.
I don't deserve it, but the thing that I don't
want to feel is that I'm faking it somehow.
Feeling like you don't deserve success, being
sad sometimes -- those are normal, but they're
not really socially acceptable to talk about,
so I figured bleeehh.
More socially acceptable is saying, "I"m so
overworked, I work all the time and I'm overwhelmed!"
which I AM!
There's a lot of things we could be doing
with our time and resources... but I don't
know what to do.
That decision is really hard.
It occurred to me today -- that's a lie, it
didn't occur to me; John actually said it
to me on the phone when we were talking -- that
I should just ask.
You're the reason all of this exists; what
do you think we should do?
So I made a survey.
You can rank different things that we might
want to do in order of how much you think
we should do them, and then add if you have
other ideas for what we should do with the
power of this community.
That's, like, why didn't, like, what's wrong
with me that I didn't think of that before?!
I have an amazing community that's supporting
all of the things we're doing, why don't I
ask them -- let you make the decision?
I don't want to!
That sounds hard!
So yeah, I was feeling a little down yesterday.
That happens, I think, to everyone...
I'm feeling better now.
On the list of things that I am grateful for
because of this thing, that's pretty high
up there.
This is always there for me, to be a thing
that I need to do to motivate me, to get out
of bed, to make a thing, to be a part of something...
thanks.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
And sometimes giant balls just appear!
It's a whole new, like, space-time thing.
Oh my god, that was a big ball!
[Hank singing] Somebody once told me the world
is gonna roll me, I ain't the sharpest tool
in the shed.
Ahhhahahaha...
Did you like that?
You like Smash Mouth?
Is that better?
So have you ever seen the movie E.T.?